[Music]
welcome to talks it's radio the meaning
connection with host Mary similar car
and frequent contributor Alexander
Wesley in the words of dr. Victor
Frankel ever more people have the means
to live but no meaning to live for
that's what we'll be addressing on
today's show join us now as we continue
the quest
it's talked since radio the meaning
connection until Unicom and now here's
your host Mary Similac oh good afternoon
and good evening everyone welcome to
talks it's radio the meaning connection
my name is Mary Somalia and I'm going to
be your host every Friday at the same
time same station with our wonderful
radio producers togi net radio with me
today on the line we have my business
partner Alexander Vesely live from
Vienna Austria Allen
along with their honored guests mrs.
Ellie Franko Alex how are you today hi
Mary it's certainly good to hear you
again and to be talking to you yes why
don't we tell our listeners a little bit
about how the radio show came about I'll
start and you chime in as you feel like
it as most of you know who are listening
Alex and I are the producers of and alex
is the award-winning director of the
upcoming documentary to be released July
1st Victor Franco movie a movie about
Alex's grandfather dr. Victor Franco dr.
Frank was probably best known around the
world for those of you listening who may
not be aware as the author of the
landmark book man's search for meaning
and he's often been called the greatest
thinker of the 20th century and we're so
proud of what alex has done and we won
the diamond award for the California
Film Awards best documentary in its
class in early earlier this year so it's
a even if we don't go any further with
the film although I know you people out
there in the world are very excited to
get your hands on it we are very proud
of what alex has done so far and and
grateful that we've been able to do that
and what you
duh Mary oh thank you I wanted to ask
you about a little bit more about the
movie I noticed that when we were
dealing with all the different people in
the film we've got some wonderful
friends of your grandmother's
and this is why don't you introduce your
grandmother first and then have her tell
us how she felt about the film when she
first saw introduce my grandmother
that's something I've never done before
it's you for me being interviewed for my
grandson
well he's so good at everything yeah
Ellie Frankel and well for me she's
mostly just a grandma and you are only
my grandson and nothing else
a beloved grandson and and you meant a
lot for us especially for Victor both
the grandchildren yes and and I would
say this my family my daughter and her
family helped him to take away food
fussing be grounded to be grounded in in
this world again and I think I think you
did that too because he knew you a long
time before we came along yes
you see to start with with what people
and then it's going to the son-in-law
and then to the grandchildren oh he was
very proud of the great children and he
enjoyed it and I'm sure the family
helped him a lot to find his place on
this earth again right mrs. Franco um
before I actually talk to you they don't
call me mrs. Frankie but my name is
Ellie can I call you Miss Ellie then of
course okay Miss Ellie thank you
but when I first started getting to know
your story
after reading the wonderful biography by
Don Klingberg who's now a friend of mine
as well
I noticed that not only God but a lot of
people described you as the warmth
behind the light and as a woman
and I'm a member of a group of women
entrepreneurs a lot of whom are
listening today I think you're the
perfect role model for women because no
matter what choice we made in our lives
whether we had a major career or own or
whether we married and had children as
you did to be a real partner and a life
partner in the work of your husband the
way you did was amazing and also go on
to raise a family so you you deserve a
lot of credit and I think that you're
the perfect role model for us this I
cannot save you if I'm an old male but
you see when I met rich door it was
something happened to him and to me and
it was unbelievable he a very high
educated man and I had to a girl and
nobody would have believed that such a
copy would survive and what turned out
it was a wonderful marriage and each day
was a gift from heaven for both of us
for him and for me and after having our
daughter and afterwards she married a
wonderful management and then the
grandchildren Alexandra and Katya this
was the greatest gift for Victor and for
me too and the otherwise I think he
wouldn't have such a long life without
the this wonderful family well that's
the important part and you helped to
create that not only that but the
amazing work that he did when you work
just as hard as he did when I met Victor
he was killed to commit suicide he has
written his book and then he was nothing
was in wait of him and thanks to him I
came into his life and right now at the
new life and it was a wonderful life
yes it was a thought it was easy you
know I want to talk about that a little
bit more after the break we're going to
be coming up here on our first
commercial break unfortunately in just
about 30 seconds but I do want to pursue
that when we come back because I think
that's a very important line of
questioning everyone wants to know how
did you meet Victor where did you guys
meet and how how would where your lives
as a couple affected by his experiences
in the Holocaust so let's talk about
that after the break
[Music]
this is toxins radio the meaning
connection it's been said that meaning
cannot be found it cannot be given it's
constantly changing evolving and though
you may not have identified it when it's
missing you know it and that's why we're
here
it's talked since radio the meaning
connection and we'll be back with more
right after the hey welcome back
everyone to talk sense radio the meaning
connection we are live from California
and Vienna Austria with our guest
Alexander Vesely and his grandmother
mrs. le Franco so mrs. Franco we wanted
to get back to the point we were
discussing about how you mailed it to
her so why don't you tell us that story
you have no idea about fictive Hartley
he was an absolute stranger for me and
when I came into his life you know I had
to beg for a bad for a patient and I
worked at it at the same hospital a
different okay station and we have
operated surgery on the patient if he
needed a bed and my boss asked me le try
to fight from a pet for participation
for two nights and friends as said to me
try it bye-bye
Viktor Frankl I have had no idea who is
Victor Huntley so I went down to his
station and was waiting and he came out
from a room and I went to him and
politely asked him could you lack I
kindly lent us four to two days a pet
for a patient and he looked at me and
gave no answer
and I thought my psychiatrist he is not
not fully aware what he's doing he said
okay you can have the bed so
thank you went away went to my boss and
said okay I have the bed for me it was
over
and two days later I met him again in
the hospital and he said oh it was
wonderful to meet you again I have so
tired teeth but pains you must bring me
- - to your department and and for me I
was young and it's a funny thing so I
picked him up and brought him up to date
the department and when we enter to whom
he said to me frankly speaking I have no
pains but my only wish was to meet you
again
oh it was kind of and it started
everything and you see after a few days
he invited me to visit his his home and
it was interesting it was shortly after
the war and in in this home we are
living aging papers and he has had
nothing we were sitting on the floor it
was all still destroyed by the war we're
talking no windows nothing absolutely
nothing but we were sitting at the floor
and he told me about the concentration
camp everything and now I see it for the
first time he was crying and after two
hours when he stopped telling me all
this he said to me but from now on I
never will speak it in this home about
the concentration camp and he kept this
up to his death he never woke in his
private home again about the
concentration camp and from that moment
on our togetherness started it was for
me not an easy life but I was used to a
very hard life maybe Alexander can tell
you or show you sometimes picture
and in which way I grew up extremely
poor but we found together this highly a
wonderful man a bright man and he a
practically an educated girl and what
turned out a marriage for over 52 years
and each day was was a gift from him at
least that's wonderful I'm sure I'm sure
also for him and and when our daughter
was born it was it's unbelievable how
happy he was and then later when we
became going to parents few people know
that most of the books by Viktor Frankl
they would not exist had you not written
them we talked we discussed everything
together and you see later on I started
typing all things for for him all books
all letters everything and and when
something I didn't understand that stop
that's it I don't write it down you must
hide put it in a way so that everyone
can understand it and he tried to make
this and when I said okay now it's okay
I typed it and it made its way out in
the world
well that's oh that was a big gift to
him because I think one of the beauties
of his theories and one of the beauties
of his writings and obviously you had an
influence on this is the simplicity so
that anyone regardless of their station
in life could understand it and that's
what makes it so powerful that's what he
was always trying to do he was not
trying to impress with his academia with
his wisdom all right and he tried
sometimes for hours tell me if that's
true no he tried for hours to simplify a
sentence or an idea that he had until he
has so much condensed that it was
perfect and that you could not change or
modify anything anymore reduce it
anymore
without taking away from it and this was
always his goal and not all people in
academia are this way exactly sometimes
local therapy is seen in the wrong light
because they say it's so easy to
understand yet that was really the
effort that he took to take these very
complex ideas and put them in simple
words well and that's the beauty of it
today you helped him with yes yeah I'm
not try and it was sometimes very loud
in our apartment but when a father of
Alexander came for the first time to our
apartment and he he he he thought we are
playing a play it was always very loud
in our you too you are we both of your
strong carry right so you know you could
keep up with him yes absolutely
good thing I wasn't there huh Alex well
you could have kept up with him made our
life very interesting and of course and
it each day was for me was a gift really
it was a gift we have a questioner wrote
in and said which of the many positive
personality traits that Victor had as a
person and as a husband did you most
value and why you see he was first of
all he was extremely clever he was very
a very bright man and he has a lot of
humor he could laugh he could behave
like a child and it it never was
admitted in our life who was wasted for
anything
it was always filled up with with with
something
Nataly that offered with work but never
ii was went was in our life it was not
filled with such something yeah that's
true
he was always funny as
you are Alex yeah I'm with you I guess
everybody sometimes and I'm Victor
yeah well he's exceptionally bright too
and also very funny
I'm sure he's so dude he and I are on
the phone sometimes for hours laughing
and talking and we should be working
really and singing yeah I'm singing yeah
I think she's a wonderful singer and
Victor was a wonderful singer
yes a I didn't know that about Victor I
didn't know he was very musical yeah
very musical yes and I thought I am also
a very good singer and whenever I
started singing Victor wasn't yeah I was
kneeling down kneeling down and said
please I give you whatever you wish but
stop singing musical and in fact the sig
nation for this radio show is a tango
that he composed and he does he loved
music and he was loved by many musicians
very much and did he play the piano as
well yeah of course not on the piano
meant many instruments on the mountains
but this is a guitar guitar you played
guitar
he was many-fold
a talented man only in the kitchen he
was not a talented man he had you for
that and for a lot of other things yeah
yeah it just sounds like a wonderful
wonderful marriage and I'm delighted I'm
delighted that we're that you allowed us
to use the tango for our radio show
because it's never been heard before but
they're going to the world's gonna hear
it now all the time we're down to one
minute to our next commercial break so
ok we'll we'll wrap it up alex is there
anything we could say really quickly in
one minute
oh well in one minute I don't know where
to start but yeah the tango the tango
that was typical it was very you know
the one side he was this giant who had
these deep thoughts and on the other
side he could be like a child
and then here I'm up and say hey I
composed this just for fun really I mean
he really enjoyed the little things and
I think that's amazing for someone who
has had the life that he had absolutely
really dark times to make his way back
and to prove that healing is possible
and that you can heal yourself where you
go
dr. Victor Frankel termed one of the
greatest thinkers of the 20th century
contingent that meaning can be found
everywhere even in the smallest Hut yet
you'll find millionaires and they have
no meaning be sure to check out the
website Victor VI Katie Orr and I
movie.com as dr. Frankel is the
inspiration for the movie and for the
show toxins ready the meaning connection
ontogenetic calm now let's get back to
our host Mary Sinha Luca welcome back to
toxins radio the meaning connection with
Mary simile cahier in beautiful Southern
California
it's one boringly beautiful day after
the other out here and Alexander Vesely
and his grandmother mrs. le Franco in
Vienna Austria I think we're having a
great show what do you guys think I do
not understand every word very isolating
in here in Vienna I know I was bombarded
by people they whole day asking me
questions but this was in my apartment
and the job and it was easier right
right right
well let's talk a little bit about
meaning and purpose in life because our
listeners are really interested in the
search for meaning not only in dr.
Franco's era and your era mrs. Franco
but also in contemporary times and we
had a good question come in today from
David Halliwell who always writes
wonderful questions he's such a big
brain himself and he says how has the
search for meaning in your opinion
changed in the past two decades and what
advice would you have for young people
growing up in today's world
you ask me you see next to my apartment
is that so-called center of a Victor
Franklin Vienna and by which they are
coming at least 30 to 50 young people
from schools and it's interesting
watching these people you know young
people very high self-esteem when they
came and when they go through this
Center and after going away there are
different people they are talking like
human beings are interested in many
other things not only in cigarettes and
and and sex and so on they learn
something life consists of different
things not only on very simple things
and this to watch on young people is for
me very interesting and so it was good
that Victor existed in this world and oh
yes I'm sure he has given many people
around the world something to think a
bit deep about their lives not to take
it as granted and so many people I know
they they are doing nothing out of their
life yeah
using the life and absolute nothing and
now to watch this and these young people
how how they need something for further
life it's it's wonderful to see and to
see for me which I have keep up my
personal life I've never been on
vacation I do not know what it what it
means to to to to to to to to walk
around the streets and do nothing I was
sitting in a coffee shop I only was
working together with Vika Victor but
when I see what turns out it was
meaningful it was a wonderful fulfilled
life for Victor and also for me
after all I'm close to 87 years so my my
life is coming to an end but I can look
back and say it was a wonderful life
from the peak from the start on being
brought up in an extremely poor family
and I started working when I was 9 years
of age otherwise we wouldn't have
survived but it was it was a wonderful
meaningful life and it's easy to die
because I see in a way I lived an
extremely rich life and and having not
only being married with such a great man
but having a wonderful daughter a
wonderful family and so the Lord has
given me I do not know why but he has
given me a lot well because you're a
very special person too I read about how
smart you were when you were growing up
in school oh I am NOT a special person
but but I'm a simple person but the Lord
has me give me a brain so sometimes I
start thinking do I deserve all this but
after all it's up to the Lord
yes yes it is you know you and I talked
briefly about this when we first spoke
on the phone a couple of months ago I
lost my husband in 97 as well and I've
told this to Alexander it's been it's
been a challenge to read you because my
life was defined by him and his work for
a long time as well and it has been a
challenge for me to uncover new meaning
in my life and I say to Alex all the
time you I went through tragedies I lost
my grandmother my mother my father my
husband to cancer and my best friend to
murder and then yet I I call myself
having been in a vat of mud moving to
California and being and landed in a vat
of Sun
Shyne after I met Alex so this whole
movie and the whole project has really
given my life new meaning and I think
our listeners would like to know after
Victor passed away how or passed on as
we say in Catholicism how have you
defined your new meaning you see Victor
left so many things after his death I
frankly speaking when he went before he
died he said to me le took everything
what what what is in our home and is in
connection with local therapy throw it
away and leave you alive you have never
lived your personal life you lived from
local therapy and for your family and
for heaven knows but you have never
lived your life and in a way it's the
way I've never been on vacation I do not
know something to sit down in a coffee
shop I'd never go to a theatre at all
things I do not know but now if I'm
going through all these letters from
from prominent people from the last
century it's a wonderful sitting down
for hours and going all this - it's it's
it's a again a gift yes I can't wait to
come to the end and see some of those
letters myself yeah maybe but you see
funds from so many prominent people I
didn't know using my eyes Victor was not
prominent he was my husband left husband
right but but he was not a great man in
my eyes but now through these all these
letters I noticed my goodness this is
Victor front well I was wondering and I
was gonna ask Alex this - where did you
first Alex realize that your
grandparents weren't ordinary people
that they were very very famous people
well when I was a kid they were always
traveling and they would come back from
California from somewhere in the world
and that was that was actually very nice
for my sister and I because they would
always bring gifts so it slowly sank in
that there was a reason why they were
you know always traveling but I didn't
really know why because but most of my
life I was not interested in local
therapy or the theories of my
grandfather that came a little later and
then I realized what this really is
about and for me that was a discovery I
had to do myself
I have to do myself because for me it
was grandpa and grandma if you don't see
your own family as even if there might
be famous in the world you don't see
them as famous people right but you guys
are like royalty in a lot of places in
the world I mean you're really IND held
in high esteem both of you both dr.
Franco and mrs. Franco I never ever hear
anyone talk about one without the other
I never hear a description of Viktor
without and then there was Ellie you
know Ellie was central to his work and
to his life I'm sure he could not have
done half of what he did know without
you and I'm not sure that had he met
another woman
that anyone would have taken the
sacrifice and as you decided to do I
have never met anyone who would have
done just you know how we have been
caught here in Vienna in indistinct it
where we lived the Siamese twins I
landed in New York eighty-three times
Wow and but you've been there more than
I have
Australia India and and I think when he
was traveling alone when my mother was
still a baby yeah he would write you a
letter yes every every day every day you
know put me a letter
but without but you see I very often
asked myself why have I deserved this I
was not have a good girl I was a
terrible girl
and you were trouble I'm not I'm not
wow you are you are I'm not a beauty I
do not know why well you were a great
beauty I just told my assistant this
morning you were a great beauty of
seeing young pictures of you so don't
don't say that about yourself
she was probably if you would hear some
of the stories of what you did when she
was a kid she was trouble oh really
okay what's right yeah oh goodness I was
worried when you came home I told
Alexander decent yeah it was a terrible
child in school yeah I I was such a
terrible child but the teacher couldn't
help them they took a what is it a like
a plaster band-aid oh I'd put it over
her mouth yeah I read that welcome back
everyone
Alex and Miss Ellie let's continue what
we were talking about so I hear miss
Ellie was something of a rascal a bit of
a rascal growing up and why don't you
tell us a little bit more about your
early life no if I start telling you
stories about the time I couldn't end it
now ashamed
often I ask myself why I have had dances
I I cannot answer it I do not know if my
brother was absolutely the contrary he
was a very sweet boy friendly for a good
boy and I was like like a Saturn I don't
think you were like Satan that's a
terrible thing is that but did you just
have the one brother and and tell us a
little bit about your parents yes yes I
had one brother a wonderful boy he was
contrary to me he was an angel in my
eyes yes he never has done some things I
have incessantly made
he never was capable of doing this and
but you know he it was in the war and
and never returned
and my mother she didn't know that he is
dead and I couldn't tell her and she up
to her last moment in her life she
thought I found them at the name of my
brother Billy returned but of course we
cannot return he was shot down a few
days after the war its I was he a pilot
he was a soldier yes yeah okay
very simple soldier oh I'm sorry to hear
that it was a terrible time yeah a war
is something and still it happens in the
world right yeah but it's it was
terrible it was but you even though you
grew up poor and Alex and I have talked
about this that you related to him that
you felt love and love is and and
meaning is what makes the world go
around so you had that that that warm
family love and I think a lot of good
things come from that yeah in spite of
unspeakable horrors and circumstances
what since since mankind exists war also
exists and seemingly as long as as as
people exist around the world war also
exists it never stops
it's right no one can I can explain why
this I do not know why right I cannot
explain it but it's terrible it is
terrible well were your parents very
very they must have been very very smart
too both your parents my parents were
very very poor extremely poor and so
came that I started hard-working when I
was nine years of age it was a cleaning
was very Russian
laundry the loud river for other people
but now I tell you a funny story we have
been in in in Costa Rica and Kuwait try
least Pablo Casals was still alive and
Victor gave a lecture at the University
and this was transmitted via radio in in
in Puerto Rico and the next day that the
president came to us in to do the hotel
and said mr. Frank
Pablo Casals are listening to - to your
lecture would you be would you like to
visit Pablo Casals he would enjoy
meeting you so we went to public castles
and it was a moving he was at that time
already an old man but it was a moving
story he told us his mother was cleaning
the visit to the best version duty
laundry for people to earn money so that
he could study a channel and and and I
said my goodness I have ever was a
little girl and my mother also was was
was a laundry for four people
and I too was laundresses but but I was
not I never learned some instrument and
and suddenly he stood up went away come
back and give a high specific yeah he
gave me a pearl and said he bought my
girl necklace and he told me he grew up
like me in a very poor family and to to
to to to have the money that he her son
can study
chello she was loudly Peppa foreign
people's okay and he came to me and and
gave a parallel
Department man manic and said for my
first money I bought this for my mother
but uh his mother was dead now I have
this this pearl here imaginable to you
it's unbelievable
well you're like a mother to the world
now because so many people know about
you in fact yesterday on this view for
people don't know know but that's that's
true what you say marry a lot of yeah
coming to to Elia when they meet her on
the street they stop her and and they
tell her all their problems problems are
bigger problems and you do therapy on
the spot on the street Viktor when I
went shopping and and returned lately he
always asked me on which corner have you
made secretary and it's telling me all
stories I'm not so interested but I
everyone tells me everything you do it
well and and and they have nothing to
pay for it well that's what we'll start
calling you will start calling you
mother to the world now last night I was
talking to another friend of yours Jay
Levinson and he said you're like a
mother to him travels dr. Jay Levinson
from Baltimore I know him I like him he
is he's a great man and then he became
like a son for us it was a wonderful
assistant for Vic well he told me to
tell you hello how are you connected
with Jay Levinson Mary knows everyone
yeah well I be I have become friends
with Jay Levinson Don Klingberg earning
average I'm becoming friends with all
the actors in the movie oh I see eyes
and everybody tells me wonderful Miss
Ellie stories but Jay said you were like
a mother to him he's going to be on our
radio show next Friday Oh Wanda
yeah you see in a way we have been very
rich people that we have met so many
wonderful people well not many people
can say that I have friends all over the
world like you can I mean it's very
important this is true but the in Vienna
I have not too much friends but you
probably need to hide in Vienna because
otherwise just be imitated with people
head to toe hi I am not sure if it was
the right place for Viktor maybe in
another country we have it had been
easier but that's the way it is now I
cannot change it normally right yeah and
hopefully I will die here right I think
it was the right place because he it was
a very important medical and cultural
center of Europe and and it in his
experiences in the Holocaust had to
create you know a greater desire to
improve his hometown yeah I would
imagine that he was thought about
leaving after he came back and and he
made a conscious choice to stay there
and thank God he did so you met you he
had the possibility to flee if you know
the political situation nobody knew
after the war it couldn't change any
moment so he made sure that he could go
to Australia as his sister had done
Stella right and so he had a permit to
enter Australia he applied for that and
he got it in the 40s and he traveled
there to visit her and she traveled to
Vienna to visit him but I think
otherwise nothing really could have got
him out of Vienna I think he loved it
it's a very quiet place too compared to
other cities and also there's the rocks
Mountain nearby mountain climbing was
his most like the hobby and and you know
a
- yeah I learned many things on advocate
aside yeah it was never my wish to climb
mountains now I like it yeah oh really
you did it I would have been frightened
out of my mind I would never could have
done that I said I thought if I go with
him if I stop by a certain degree degree
yeah
and so he went wherever we have been we
went together climbing in a way I
stopped him going couldn't climb a more
difficult and more dangerous degree
right so once again you saved his life
once again you saved his life you should
it's a couple of times you see but it
it's a wonderful feeling if you are
climb if you are climbing good then up
on the top it's a wonderful feeling
yes Wow Carrie our producer is just
giving me the the news that we only have
ten seconds now to wrap up our show can
you believe an hour's gone by already
now we have 7 seconds so mrs. Franco I
want to say thank you so much for being
on our first show it's been great I
think you [ __ ] up my heart it was the
first no hi I'm afraid you'll like thank
you everyone for joining us toxin
trachea by Alex by being a part of talk
Saints radio the meaning connection I'm
talking a calm with your host Mary
similar code